things doesn't possibly dramatically
change you still need to find a problem
okay and once you find the problem you
need to search for people that have the
same problem and wants to solve the
symbol
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders let's talk
about research and innovation meet
ranilani head of emerging technologies
at innovation etni at cisco israel
ron is also co-founder of porkshift io
acquired by cisco a pioneer in the cloud
native security market
prior to port shift ron held executive
leadership position with checkpoint
software technologies leading network
security appliances business line
earlier run co-founded blade fusion the
first industry standard for multi-bladed
security appliance for enterprise and
prior to that he managed an engineering
team of exceptional researchers and
developers in distributed computing at
main control acquired by ibm
ron is the inventor and author of more
than 10 patents most of which are in the
field of cyber security he holds a bsc
and an msc in computer science with
honors from the technology
[Music]
ron ilani welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for joining me how are
you
i'm great uh thank you for for having me
and great to have this uh little chat or
fire slide chat so to speak it's gonna
be it's gonna be fantastic
ron you're a serial entrepreneur
you're an inventor uh you're a
technologist you're a researcher
and you know your curiosity you know is
you know runs through your journey and i
know and i'm looking forward to picking
your brain on some of the some of these
experiences that you've had and the
insights that you've gained and both on
the entrepreneurial side on the
invention side and the curiosity side
but even before we do that i want to go
back in time to growing up in africa and
tell me just a little bit about about
your very non-traditional upbringing as
a kid
yeah so uh well right you can say that
literally i was uh well i was growing
with the monkeys
during the 17th
late late seventies i'm joking of course
so uh actually my childhood was uh in
west africa nigeria i spent uh several
years with my parents there were
there was actually some
i would say uh from the ministry of
defense
you know uh being some positive there
uh so i spent there uh you know most of
my childhood but you know until the i
think the
fifth grade
um
and uh yeah it was an interesting
experience i can say that you know uh
uh it was very interesting in the sense
that uh
you know uh actually
what you have
as a kid okay uh in israel and what you
had as a kid
in africa but then was very different
uh
you know both fine you know growing up
uh learning studying by the way i i
studied the first grade
it in a class with
another single student so we were two in
the first grade
yeah so it was so it was pretty
interesting pretty unique
and yes when i arrived you know in
israel uh i've actually arrived with a
language actually with two languages
with both english but also the native
evil language so yes this is also
another interesting story that uh
i can definitely i don't know how to
speak today but it was very cool to
speak when i was a kid at least with the
native
yeah so quite an interesting uh
experience i can say and uh i think
you know growing up in a untraditional
classical
environment um
to some extent contribute uh to the way
that
uh you know you can cope with different
situations in a different way okay it's
not it's not a classical growing up
experience if you you know if you travel
between
countries specifically africa
specifically in the late 70s back then
so yeah that's the story
if you had to go throughout your journey
and to
pinpoint the time that
that that sparked your curiosity as an
inventor and as a scientist
um
is there a moment like that were you
always from childhood that curious or or
was there something that changed
the way that you saw your own curiosity
that led you down this path
i think well the number one
sort of pillar okay that
at least for me personally was that
every time that you are um sort of uh
introduced to uh
something that you learn
you want to do it a little bit different
you find something that you are
you are not okay with it i mean it's not
it
it's it's you are not okay you could do
some improvement and the improvement
will make it better
i mean this is something that is almost
fundamental not only you know in
startups and you know being an
entrepreneur but but even on a
day-to-day
uh and for me you know it's on a
personal basis you you you know the way
that you uh drive to work the way that
you raise your kids the way
on the little things in life or you know
that that you have
and do um
this is probably the number one i would
say parameters that you know sort of
takes you uh down the road
talk to me a little bit about
the different things you've done so
you're you're curious about cyber
security you're curious about devops
you took that curiosity to the
entrepreneurial world
you've been a part of some phenomenal
organizations like entrepreneur
residents of the phenomenal
team eight you've founded two companies
that were very successful and today
you're you're head of emerging
technologies and innovation at cisco
israel
is there sort of a common thread amongst
these things are you more of an
entrepreneur are you more of a
researcher
what sort of you know
how do you describe
who you are you know within this
ecosystem
yeah i think it's it's really a
combination of several things uh
let me give you an example and and it's
always
you know and
it always starts with with something
that really binds to what i described
formally that you are not quote-unquote
happy with okay and you want to create a
change you want to make something that
will change the world or change the way
we are doing things in a traditional way
and i'll give you a very simple example
well i have several of them but you know
the most i was i would say prominent one
is the one for instance with portrait
okay so i've been with
um you know checkpoint almost 10 years
and i was leading a pretty large
engineer organization of several
hundreds folks that did you know
firewall and network security and what
what i learned that
uh you know every time that you sort of
deploy when you speak with customer and
you want to do a new project it's always
sort of almost an open heart transplant
for a lack of better term uh
it's always a project that you need
acceptance and it takes a lot of time
and you are always the persona man grata
as the security officer when you want to
uh to you know to deploy a new firewall
into the actual uh operation environment
and then we start i mean
in the modern uh application environment
where you have containers you have
kubernetes you have serverless amd
uh network classical network security
network segmentation can it be so i
would say um
none i would say operate operationally
sensitive and you you need the solution
to be able to be a
decoupled from the network to some
extent
and also uh
to be able to uh be provisioned to the
developers and devops in their own tools
you cannot really do it in the old way
that you know you did you did things in
the past and and and this is what you
know how you know portrait was born by
the notion of doing some sort of uh um
application based uh and segmentation
but the couple from the network without
again without you know putting a lot of
uh i would say
friction with with the developers even
the name portrait by the way is like
part is really left it's like shift left
but also shifting from ports to
something else and something else is a
different notion
of you know uh sort of micro
segmentation this is how the company
started to change the way that you do
network segment segmentation we actually
chose you know being on the cloud native
environment we chose
underlying infrastructure which is
called easter service mesh as you know
as the
underlying technology to be able to do
this type of
i would say operation but we learned
very fast that
it's not enough okay which is by the way
it's always it's not enough to have a
great technology and fall in love with
your idea of your product you really
need to see where the market is and back
then
serve and i'm talking about like four
four and a half years ago uh service
match was really cool
technology really cool cool product but
we didn't really see a lot of adoption
in the market because you know users and
customers were coping with how can i
secure my containers and my kubernetes
let the law on them in the service mesh
let me let me have something which is
much more basic
so again we we change okay we we
understood that the vision is is is good
but we need to change a little bit the
focus we need to address the same point
which is much more fundamental much more
basic but in the same principle no
frictions and obviously and being able
to and being deployed with uh i would
say with the double stool so we started
doing uh i would say a concept of uh and
taking the same i would say
product and technology infrastructure to
uh to provide the same functionality
which is
what we call the pyramid of necessities
something with the very something with
the very base uh i would say requirement
which is let's say
uh vulnerabilities and visibility for
those containers and then configuration
management and only then i would say you
know the more advanced functionality and
with that actually and we went to the
market which proven to be very very
successful because again we turned out
to be what we call a one-stop shop okay
for kubernetes security but again
starting from the very base the idea is
that
for that again that the main id well no
friction no agents for you know to
install not a lot of effort to for the
developers and devops in order to deploy
the product and this is sort of how you
know the
um
you know the company and the technology
grew and the lesson learned is that
there are two you know
first you you need to to to have the
drive okay
uh
to
not accept what is being introduced by
current solution in the card market and
the second thing is that
you know if there is a wall which is
like 9
90 feet high i mean if you run
um much more faster it doesn't really
mean that you will pass it so
you need to find another way to pass the
wall and in our cases was to understand
that you know for instance in this
example service mesh is something that
is not adopted and we need to change a
bit okay our direction
in order to hit the right mark and then
there are users and this is the story of
portrait by the way
and this was also the story of blade
fusion okay which was another company
that i founded but again the least
common
dominant nominator there is to find
something
uh which is not okay in the car
technology okay to try to fix it
and but to do it in a unique way
if you are targeting i would say
a hyperscaler market
it has a great advantage for instance uh
we actually decided to go with cloud
native containers and kubernetes because
we find out that you know the adoption
we sort of um
assumed okay that this would be like uh
the new form factor that inherit the
earth so to speak so it worked out very
good for us okay and but again it's
now when you when you started porch
shift and you made that decision or you
you sort of made that prediction that
this is going to be the the bread and
butter for for future cloud native
companies was that trivial because today
everybody sort of you know agrees to
this but was that was that already
trivial about that it's what's
absolutely not true because when we
talked with uh
you know with with csos okay which are
the owners of the uh you know
you know the security uh sort of uh
realm
kubernetes and we have actually
containers or something that is on the
edge okay it was something there but you
know nobody really sort of
understood that this is going to be one
day a huge issue
first to be able to visualize to
understand what i have deployed and
second of all obviously to secure them
then the same story came with kubernetes
okay kubernetes started very small with
google
yeah and uh
and very fast grew like you know
uh
gigantic uh you know uh uh dimensions
and so
in some cases we sort of
we gambled yeah i might say we gamble
obviously but it was an educated guess i
would say um that being said
you know
every educate educated guess usually is
based on the on on some working
assumption our working assumption that
if we are talking with let's say
then organization and without those
organizations we see like uh we're
talking with the right persona with the
devops and we are hearing the same story
all over again it makes sense that it
will happen down the road so yeah so we
definitely gambled on those on this
domain and marketed it you know we were
we were
i love it and i love the intentionality
behind it but but this this dissonance
between
the you know you as an inventor and as a
researcher you as an entrepreneur you're
talking about this
sort of the there is a difference
between creating this innovative
technology that is meant to do something
that has never been done before but do
it in a way that that cons that the
consumers will enjoy will fix their
fundamental pyramid of needs
and
was that easy sort of balancing those
two worlds for you on one hand
developing innovative technology and and
assimilating it to consumers behavior or
or did you find that challenging
bridging those two worlds together
yeah so
it's always challenging okay it's always
challenging
you know to bridge between those two
worlds from one hand but from the other
hand this is really really
the
one of the main problem one of the main
i would
being able to bridge between
what you want to bring
as a technology to a real pain point and
in some cases the pain point is even not
clear to the user itself himself
uh in some cases you need soda to uh
educate the market that there is already
pain point there and if it doesn't see
it today he will see this you know
tomorrow right yeah obviously it's much
more challenging to you know to cover
those type of uh you know uh of uh i
would say challenges that being said
uh the merit is much greater because if
you are right
then what starts today is something very
small can turn out to be something huge
down the road in our cats it was very
clear with containers kubernetes and
service mesh and all of those you know
put cloud-native technologies obviously
but uh yeah so this is definitely one of
them i would say major tasks that you
know i see ourselves as you know
founders and entrepreneurs as you know
mustering it's almost like an art so you
know
and and so following on that art today
is his head of emerging technologies
innovation at cisco but but also sort of
bring together your time as
entrepreneurial residents at team eight
and the ideation process for blade
fusion
what is sort of your day-to-day like so
how do you what is sort of the the
persona that you have to bring as you're
evaluating these new opportunities and
these new technologies yeah so yeah one
of our just you know decision to to join
cisco you know our acquisition is i
think it's also pretty unique because
we didn't really join cisco just in the
corporate we we joined what we call the
ethnic emerging technology incubation
group which was
which is a fairly new uh division within
uh
within cisco and the uh
and the charter of this division was
within cisco is essentially to bring
sort of the next generation
technologies and product that we take
cisco i would say to the you know to the
to the next phase in in the cisco
journey
and the opportunity was really to take
what we have with worksheet that was
done and i would say in a fairly limited
scale and to turn it into something
grander
uh as part of what we call the cloud
native
uh you know security
domain but also as you know
you know is leading the etna site here
in uh
in israel
opening new ventures yeah
and one of the very interesting buckets
that we we are also
sort of entertaining is the machine
learning ai specifically more
specifically mlabs and this is something
that
does not really relate to security or
cloud native security it's totally on a
different you know bucket okay so to
speak but you know
that being said
very interesting and this is again
another very unique opportunity to take
to take our experience as you know as a
founder of company and bring it and
create a new ventures and by the way
we have moderate the same journey with
uh
uh the mlaps uh that we're doing today
with cisco as we have the portrait i
mean i mean that things doesn't possibly
dramatically change you still need to
find a problem okay and once you find
the problem you need to search for
people that have the same problem and
wants to solve the symbol and then once
you find those people those are your
audience or your
design partners usually you think of
this solution that you would pitch to
them and once you've pitched them the
solution you ask them whether they would
like to use this type of solution and
then the third layer of you know
validation is okay once you use this
type of
solution whether you want to pay for it
so this is again so the main fundamental
question stays the same doesn't really
matter whether you are
running a startup you know uh but
even doing a new venture within uh
you know corporate
cisco the difference i think and what
we're doing today is the fact that
we can fail one and four
we can decide that uh
we want to restart i mean that this idea
wasn't good we need to we want to change
the idea
uh
and in you know in etna cisco again if
it's nobody really wants to fail don't
get me wrong but
the the implications are totally
different i it's more like a playground
i can decide that i want to move to a
different story in a different venture
nothing will happen and startup you know
the the pivot or the journey that i
described to you as moving from
something
from something very
that we decided to do to something else
was not an easy task it was not as an
easy decision this is you know the the
decision has a lot of implication of
budget and the company and the focus
again because the resources are much
more i would say
smaller in the extent
but
incredible the bottom line is that you
still need to answer the same question
and every venture that you you you you
start regardless whether it's like you
do it on the startup or or and
and this one by the way this is one of
the reasons why we decided to join cisco
in dni
uh because
this brings that an opportunity for us
as a team
uh to create more stuff and as a team by
the way we weren't you know we weren't
distributing the organization we are
still working as you know the porsche
team we extended obviously we have more
people we are we are growing here
dramatically
but again uh this is where we see the
opportunity in
creating new products and new things and
this is where we have the excitement and
we are
we are we are it sounds uh it sounds
extremely exciting both on an
entrepreneurial level but also on an
inventor and research level bridging two
distinct but but amazing worlds together
and ron i really want to thank you for
taking the time to to share these 20
minutes with me talking about both the
entrepreneurial journey of blade fusion
and port shift but also a little bit
about today's role within cisco and how
you're thinking through these this
problem solution mindset and i can't
wait to continue following your work
and seeing what what new things you come
up with and thank you very much for your
time fantastic and thank you for having
me today
thank you